vous l'avez vu Renault mise beaucoup sur
le tout électrique ici au Salon de
l'automobile mais comment réagissent les
autres constructeurs Alice Gastine est
allé à leur rencontre pour faire le
point pour ce Mondial de l'OTO 2012 de
Paris encore une fois les 270 marques
présentes rivalisent d'ingéniosité dans
le domaine de l'électrique et de
l'hybride tour d'horizon des
constructeurs installés dans les
ivelines on a une offre la Peugeot
laillon voiture tout électrique mais une
voiture tout électrique encore
aujourd'hui inévitablement présente de
réelle contrainte d'autonomie donc une
voiture électrique et on pense nous pour
encore quelques années quand même sera
forcément concentré à une un usage quasi
strictement urbain on croit beaucoup
plus dans la technologie de l'hybride
diesel on va pouvoir proposer des
voitures comme une 3008 hybride 4 et
bien qui fait 200 chevaux qui propose
quatre roues motrices et qui est
homologué à environ 4,5 de diesel au
sang la marque française porte aussi un
intérêt tout particulier aux pays en
voie de développement elle présente
cette année une berline 301 réservée au
marché asiatique russes et africains
direction le stand de BMW le
constructeur allemand présente cette
année sa nouvelle marque écologique
explication avec le responsable
France vous avez sous les yeux les BMW
i8 Concept et i3 Concept qui sont à 80 %
à peu près identiques à ce que seront
les modèles de série dans un an ces
voitures sont faites pour
l'électromobilité avec des matériaux
ultra légers comme la fibre de carbone
ou l'aluminium et en plus totalement
responsable de l'environnement puisqu'on
utilise beaucoup de matériaux
recyclés sur ces deux voitures les
premiers véhicules seront commercialisés
fin 2013 chez Ford c'est une grande
première le constructeur américain
s'apprête à commercialiser deux
véhicules électriques et hybrides en
France ces modèles étaient pour
l'instant uniquement disponible aux
États-Unis où le marché de l'électrique
et de l'hybride représente 5 % du
secteur automobile
on présente une Focus 100 % électrique
donc là vous n'avez pas de moteur
thermique vous avez 150 km d'autonomie
c'est parfait pour un usage urbain ou
périurbain ou pour des usages
professionnels et à côté on présente une
Mondéo hybride qui elle va être parfaite
pour voyager parce que vous aurez une
hybridation c'est l'association d'un
moteur électrique à d'un moteur
thermique qui vous permet en ville de
baisser considérablement les émissions
et les consommations mais malgré tout
d'avoir beaucoup d'autonomie pour
voyager quand vous voulait voyager loin
et en
famille on pense que les moteurs
thermiques ont encore des progrès à
faire et notamment chez nous nous avons
développé un moteur bicylindre qui
s'appelle le twinir nous travaillons
également sur des carburants alternatifs
faut savoir que Fiat est leader en
Europe sur le GNV le méthane donc des
c'est un carburant encore plus propre
que les GPL et nous avons aussi une
large gamme de véhicule GPL la 500
électrique sera mise sur le marché
américain l'année prochaine l'Europe
devra encore attendre on termine avec
l'umééo une PME desivelin spécialisée
dans le véhicule électrique l'électrique
c'est l'énergie du futur pour la ville
pas pour les grandes distances c'est
évident on a un problème de Capacité de
batterie mais pour la ville c'est c'est
vraiment l'énergie du futur parce que
pas de pollution pas de bruit facilité
de de pompe à essence aussi dans la
ville faut y penser c'est quand même pas
si facile que ça les progrès technique
auront lieu d'abord sur le poids du
véhicule qui qui baisse tout le temps et
aussi sur l'autonomie grâce à de
meilleures batteries mais là le saut
technologique sera fait plutôt dans 3 4
ans ou voir un peu plus sans oublier la
tzie de chez Renault le véhicule
électrique en autopartage pour l'instant
exclusivement sur le territoire
cquantinois le 78 édition salon de
l'automobile nous sommes sur le stand de
Citroën Citroën qui présente finalement
assez peu de nouveautés si ce n'est
cette DS3 cabriolet juste derrière moi
PSA en effet laissé la priorité cette
année à Peugeot où nous irons dans un
instant auparavant bonsoir Alice on va
faire avec vous un point sur les
chiffres de ce salon ce salon d'ampleur
he véritablement c'est un salon
important ce salon à Paris et oui qui
l'année dernière a accueilli plus
d'1200000 visiteurs et qui en attend
autant voir plus cette année ce sont 270
marques venant de 21 pays différents le
département des yvelin est aussi très
bien forcément représenté ici il faut
savoir que le département des evivelin
c'est le premier département automobile
en France avec deux sites d'assemblage
majeur et de recherche et développement
que sont Renault avec le Technocentre
installé à guillentour et puis PSA
Peugeot Citroën ce sont plus de 105 50
entreprises spécialisé dans l'automobile
que ce soit les constructeurs ont cité
Renault et PSM mais il y a aussi Fiat ou
encore Ford installé à Saint-Germain en
lait Mercedes ou encore BMW et puis de
nombreux équipementstiers et des bureaux
d'études merci Alice pour ces précisions
on reste sur ce salon de l'automobile on
vous fait vivre ce salon de l'automobile
du côté de la Porte de Versailles à
Paris on va aller faire un tour sur le
stand de Peugeot ce sera juste après ce
reportage consacré à quelquesunes des
nouveautés présentées lors de cette
édition le Mondial de l'UTO porte de
versaill est une vitrine pour les
constructeurs ce salon créé en 1898
présente cette année plus de 270 marques
venant de 21 pays parmi elles les
constructeurs installés dans les
Yvelines présentation des nouveautés
2012 ce crossover urbain qui est
derrière nous le 2008 concept ça c'est
une voiture qui sera présentée
commercialisée à l'été prochain donc dès
2013 crossover ça ça va mélanger les
genres ça va prendre le meilleur de la
berline c'est-à-dire la le le la tenue
de route le confort d'une berline mais
ça va lui adjoindre le l'habitabilité
d'un monospace avec le look beaucoup
plus dynamique et moderne d'un
suvun 44 entre guillemets notamment avec
la présentation de la série 1 tris
portes du Touring Série 3 et surtout
j'ai envie de dire puisque c'est sa
première mondiale de l'active Tourer qui
est en fait le premier véritable
monospace dans la gamme BMW on commence
par le remplaçant du Kuga le nouveau
Kuga le 4x4 de la GAM Ford il y a la
nouvelle Mondeo la future grande berline
le porte-drapeau de la gamme il y a un
tout petit 4x4 qui s'appelle l'Ecosport
qui arrivera un petit peu plus tard et à
cela s'ajoute le resyage de la fiesta et
le nouveau Bmax qui sont les voitures
qui vont arriver sur le marché dans les
tous prochains jours dont nous
commençons la commercialisation et qui
augure déjà d'avoir un succès notable
principalement pour le Bmax qui a la
particularité d'avoir des portes très
innovantes chez Fiat la gamme 500
s'agrandit avec l'arrivée de la 501
destinée aux familles est disponible en
France dès le 10 octobre al c'est un
véhicule qu'on a voulu très émotionnel
sur les aspect coloril elle reprend les
quelques éléments esthétiques de la 500
notamment la planche de bord couleur
carrosserie mais c'est avant tout un
véhicule qu'on a voulu très rationnel
avec beaucoup d' d'habitabilité pardon
de modularité de la personnalisation et
des tarifs et des équipements à la
hauteur la marque italienne présente
également sa panda 44 qui sera
commercialisée mi-octobre le Mondial de
l'automobile se tient jusqu'au 14
octobre il a accueilli l'’année dernière
plus d'un mil
visiteurs venus du monde
entier